[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh bien les amis
nous sommes là et vous êtes là et ce
jour marque le premier jour de notre
reconstruction
le premier jour de ce long chemin qui
doit permettre la renaissance de la
droite en france
nous avons connu la défaite
nous avons déçu et nous avons parfois
écoeuré mais petit à petit semaine après
semaine mois après mois
nous nous sommes employés à rebâtir nous
nous sommes battus aux législatives cher
christian nous avons gagné cher gérard
et je suis fier de ta présence et je
t'en remercie
elle nous honore nous avons gagné aux
sénatoriales
nous avons doucement parfois trop
doucement à mon goût fait réentendre
petit à petit la voix de la droite et
vous surtout vous avez été là vous avez
déjoué tous les pronostics qui disait
qu'il n'y aurait pas de participation à
l'élection de décembre vous avez fait
entendre la force des républicains
vous leur avez montré la vitalité de ce
qui est le grand parti de la république
en france
je veux vous en remercier et je veux
surtout que vous sachiez que c'est pour
moi le plus beau des encouragements et
que si je ne lâche jamais rien
c'est parce que je sais que vous êtes là
à mes côtés merci
à partir d'aujourd'hui c'est une
nouvelle page que nous ouvrons à partir
d'aujourd'hui nous tournons le dos aux
erreurs du passé
à partir d'aujourd'hui c'est une
nouvelle droite qui commence et comme à
chaque moment de notre histoire
politique
c'est vers vous que je me tourne vous
inquiète les militants de ma famille
politique
et vous qui m'avez toujours tout donné
tout au long de mon parcours au moment
nous allons entreprendre ce grand défi
j'ai une pensée évidemment pour tous
ceux qui ont incarné dans les épreuves
la renaissance de notre famille
politique
ne l'oubliez jamais vous êtes les
héritiers d'une grande histoire une
histoire qui nous oblige vous êtes les
héritiers du général de gaulle celui qui
n'a jamais renoncé et surtout celui qui
n'a jamais dévier de son cap
vous êtes les héritiers de georges
pompidou celui qui consigne est tout à
la fois les racines et la modernité
vous êtes les héritiers de jacques
chirac le président qui aimait tant les
territoires de la france
et bien sûr vous comprendrez que j'ai
une pensée toute particulière en ce jour
pour nicolas sarkozy qui a su redonner
sa fierté à la droite
[Applaudissements]
et je tiens aussi je tiens aussi cher
bruno à rendre hommage à françois fillon
les attaques contre lui
on était souvent indignes et je lui suis
reconnaissant d'avoir porter avec force
nos idées sans jamais chercher à acheter
le calme en édulcorant son projet notre
histoire c'est la vôtre monsieur le
premier ministre
celui auquel je dois tant par les
échanges réguliers que nous avons
ensemble
celui dont je n'oublie jamais que c'est
lui qui a oeuvré pour le redressement de
l'économie de notre pays
après les erreur funeste des périodes de
françois mitterrand merci de votre
présence
monsieur balladur
c'est pour moi la présence de michèle
alliot marie dont l'attachement à la
famille gaulliste n'a jamais vacillé et
dont l'affection ne m'a jamais manqué
c'est l'histoire de bernard accoyer qui
dans cette année terrible a tenu la
barre lui qui est le premier des
militants
c'est votre histoire c'est l'histoire de
ces hommes et de ces femmes qui dans
notre famille politique avait des
convictions avait du caractère avait le
verbe ont pratiqué la politique comme je
laime celle de ses figures hautes en
couleurs à l'image de charles pasqua ou
de philippe séguin
c'est aussi à eux que je pense dans ce
moment alors je n'oublie rien de ce
passé qui fait notre force
mais je suis aussi que maintenant il
nous appartient d'écrire une nouvelle
histoire pour la droite
je vais vous dire ce que je pense je
pense profondément que de cette défaite
nous pouvons sortir plus fort à une
condition c'est que nous ayons tous les
courages et toutes les audaces parce que
pendant trop longtemps petit à petit la
droite s'est contenté de devenir une
longue gauche voire même parfois une
gauche au ralenti une droite
gestionnaire au petit pied décevantes se
contentant de débat étriqué dans
lesquelles nous assumions si peu nos
valeurs et bien aujourd'hui cette
défaite a une vertu
le fait que tout explose et que tous les
repères et été mis à terre oblige à
changer parce que ce n'est plus possible
après nos terrible défaite la droite
doit repenser sa raison d'être
les ambiguïtés des manuels macron nous
oblige à repenser ce que nous sommes
et si certains politiques dans notre
famille se sentent aujourd'hui si
impuissants parce que le gouvernement
ferait quelques réformes
j'ai la conviction que c'est parce qu'en
réalité pour eux être de droite
ce n'était pas grand chose et que quand
on bouge quelques articles dans le code
du travail
ils perdent tous leurs repères parce
qu'il n'avait pas de colonne vertébrale
pas de vis
pas de valeur
je connais trop cette tentation maintes
fois répétées de la droite française qui
cherche à acheter des brevet de
respectabilité en se trahissant regardez
moi je suis respectable puisqu'au fond
je suis si peu de droite tous ceux qui
pensent qu'il y aurait d'un côté les
archaïques et de l'autre les modernes et
que pour être moderne il faudrait
regarder du côté de la gauche
eh bien je pense tout linverse je pense
que la droite doit retrouver sa colonne
vertébrale
c'est pour cela que je suis à vos côtés
je veux vous rendre votre dignité et je
veux que nous puissions dire très
sereinement mais avec la plus grande
énergie
nous sommes de droite et nous sommes à
nouveau fier d'être de droite
après l'élection de notre parti en
décembre bien des commentateurs ils sont
allés de leur petite analyse en dix ans
attendait laurent wauquiez va mollir son
discours
ne vous inquiétez pas il va mettre un
peu d'eau dans son vin pour l'instant ce
sont des propos de tribunes mais il va
évidemment remettre le cap en direction
de la gauche
et bien je le redis eux qui sont
aujourd'hui tous surpris je ne changerai
pas et je n'ai aucune intention de
changer
il est si fréquent en politique pour
glaner quelques petits points
temporaires dans les sondages de dire
l'exact inverse de ce que l'on portait
pendant l'élection je ne me livrerai pas
à cette comédie
je leur dis que mon cas est encore plus
grave que ce qu'il pense et que ce
qu'ils peuvent imaginer
ce n'est pas une stratégie politique le
pire c'est que je pense tout ce que je
dis et que je suis convaincu que si l'on
veut redresser le pays
la droite doit aller au bout de ses
idées
alors
je connais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je connais mes amis je connais le prix à
payer je connais les caricatures que la
droite doit essuyer quand elle a dans
notre pays l'audace de redresser le
regard et je vois aussi tout ce qui est
fait pour plier notre et chine
je vois leurs regards dans les débats
quand l'on refuse de se soumettre et
qu'on leur dis très directement en face
et très calmement mais sans rien leur
lâcher linverse de ce qu'ils voudraient
entendre et bien n'ayez pas peur parce
qu'il ya cette phrase que j'aime bien de
audouard n'ayez pas peur
les coupures de presse sont celles qui
cicatrise le plus vite
mais pour rebâtir il nous faut ouvrir
les portes et les fenêtres
j'ai voulu donner sa chance à une
nouvelle génération
nous avons voulu faire monter les
talents que la droite a trop souvent
étouffés et je remercie ici christian
denis avoir aidé christian jacob fait
partie de ceux qui ne tanguent jamais
dans la tempête
jamais
je remercie bruno de m'avoir apporté son
soutien lui qui fait partie de ceux qui
portent une vraie ossature est une vraie
conviction pour ce qu'est notre famille
politique
je remercie franck qui avec la
délégation européenne dont je suis si
fier porte aussi la voix de la france au
sein du parti populaire européen
merci à toi fond et je remercie l'équipe
qui autour d'annie genevard a à peine 40
ans d'âge de moyenne elle est pleine
d'énergie elle est pleine dent vie et
surtout il aime travailler ensemble nous
allons faire monter de jeanne députés
nous allons faire monter de jeunes mères
nous allons faire monter de jeunes
militants et nous allons faire monter
des militants qui ont des cheveux blancs
comme moi mais qui ont le coeur l'homme
est généreux
mais pour rebâtir il va falloir que nous
reprenions le plaisir du débat car petit
à petit nous avons cessé de débattre
j'ai connu une époque où l'on discutait
ou le ton parfois montait le soir mais
où le lendemain une fois que le cap
était arrêté tout le monde jouait le jeu
de l'équipe et ne pratiquez pas les
petites phrases dans les couloirs pour
espérer que les micros des médias se
tendent vers vous parce que l'on tire
contre son camp willy jean petit à petit
ce sont les rivalités de personnes qui
ont remplacé les débats d'idées et ses
rivalités nous ont tués parce que les
français nous ont jugé sévèrement jean
toi qui a accepté de s'engager de
prendre la présidence de notre conseil
national tu appartiens la sensibilité
centriste
tu as toujours défendu des idées tu n'as
pas toujours été majoritaires mais tu es
toujours resté à l'intérieur de notre
famille politique parce que tu en as
respecter le débat
le débat je laime passionnément
parce que c'est cela qui fait la sève de
la vie politique et je ne sanctionnerait
jamais un membre de notre famille
politique parce qu'ils se lèvent et
qu'il dit je ne suis pas d'accord et je
veux exprimer mes idées
souvenez vous quand j'avais lancé le
débat sur le rsa et sur les dérives de
l'assistanat
souvenez vous quand j'avais commencé à
tirer les sonnettes d'alarmé sur le
fossé qui se creusait entre l'europe et
les peuples
souvenez vous quand j'avais commencé à
demander que nous arrêtions de baisser
le regard sur les questions d'identité
et de laïcité
alors que tout le monde à l'époque
sous-estimé encore la montée du
radicalisme
il m'est arrivé aussi d'essuyer les
critiques des dirigeants de notre
mouvement mais je n'ai jamais menacé de
claquer la porte
je suis toujours resté dans ma famille
politique parce que c'est en débattant
que l'on peut porter ses idées
on reste dans sa famille politique
on ne brade pas ses idées pour un poste
au gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
je veillerai je veillerai mes amis à ce
que nous ayons des débats animés
je veillerai à ce que vous ayez la
parole et pas seulement pour réagir
mais pour proposer je n'aime pas ce
gouvernement qui fait tout depuis les
ministères parisiens
eh bien je veux que notre parti lui
soient organisées à partir de la base et
de ce qu'est la vie quotidienne des
français parce que je vois monter ce
risque de déconnexion ce débat il se
fera dans le respect de chacune des
sensibilités
je veux que virginie calmels ce je veux
que guillaume pelletier dont je connais
le talent la fougue et l'énergie
je veux que damien abad qui est avec moi
dans ma région et que j'ai vu grandir et
je suis fier damien du chemin que tu
fais parcours et je veux que valérie
pécresse
je veux que eric ciotti puissent
exprimer leurs idées en toute liberté
mais en revanche je le dis je ne le
laisserai plus les petites chapelles et
les querelles d'ego affaiblir notre
famille politique
je ne distribue pas de postes aux
enchères pour acheter le silence des uns
et les autres parce que ces petites
cliques ont failli tuer les républicains
je tends la main à chacun mais il faut
maintenant qu'ils comprennent que le
temps des écuries est révolu si l'on
veut s'engager on le fait tous ensemble
je veux que l'on retrouve le plaisir de
l'engagement en commun nous sommes les
républicains
et je veux surtout que chacun comprenne
la responsabilité qui est la nôtre tout
le travail des marcheurs
gérard virginie vous l'avez si bien dit
consiste à faire croire que si l'on
n'est pas avec eux on est un archaïque
que si l'on ne pense pas comme eux on
n'a rien compris à la marche du monde
pour emmanuel macron son gouvernement
doit se tenir à l'abri de ce qu'il
appelle les passions tristes les gens
qui ne sont rien mais qui sont ces gens
qui ne sont rien
les classes moyennes de france vous ceux
qui demandent juste être respectée et
qui ont trop souvent le sentiment d'être
oubliés ceux qui expriment trop souvent
avec raison leur inquiétude pour
l'avenir de leurs enfants
ceux qui croient dans la force et la
vitalité de la république française mais
qui constate trop souvent qu'on la mise
la tête à l'envers et bien que leur
disent les marcheurs qu'ils
appartiendraient au monde d'hier qu'ils
n'ont pas la voir au chapitre que le
peuple n'est pas raisonnable et qu'on ne
peut pas lui faire confiance
mais que reste-t-il de la politique
quand on se méfie du peuple que
reste-t-il de la démocratie quand on
méprise la volonté du peuple
il voudrait nous faire croire qu'il n'y
a qu'un seul chemin que le temps du
débat politique serait finie que la
france devrait se soumettre au seul
choix qu'il propose la voix de quelques
experts qui pensent mieux que nous qui
savent mieux que nous et qui disent au
reste du monde ce qui est bon pour lui
et bien non monsieur macron nous
refusons de vous suivre
quand vous expliquer qu'il n'y a pas de
culture française
non
non monsieur macron nous refusons de
vous suivre
quand vous humilier la france en allant
en algérie et en expliquant que notre
histoire serait celle de crimes contre
l'humanité non monsieur macron nous ne
vous suivront jamais quand vous humilier
l'armée française et que vous cherchez
ensuite à leur tenir un discours inverse
et non monsieur macron nous n'acceptons
pas la façon dont vous traitez les
retraités français parce que ça n'est
pas juste non tous les français ne sont
pas sommé de se taire et de vous
applaudir il y à d'autres voies il y à
d'autres chemins et c'est la démocratie
ceux qui veulent imposer leur pensée
unique nous conduisent à l'échec et
j'aime cette phrase de philippe séguin
il est temps de montrer aux français qu
il y a plusieurs voies possibles qu'ils
ont le choix
il est temps de leur montrer qu'on les
mène vers une impasse et que l'espérance
est ailleurs nous sommes les
républicains et nous avons le devoir
pour tous les français de recréer le
débat et de réouvrir le choix c'est la
démocratie
et nous le ferons sans jamais être
sectaire
parce que c'est l'honneur de notre
famille d'avoir toujours mis l'intérêt
de la france avant les clivages
politiciens et nous le ferons en ne nous
contentant pas de dénoncer mais en ayant
toujours le souci de proposer mes amis
pour cela nous allons prendre le temps
de forger le nouveau logiciel de la
droite
mon ambition est de reconquérir tous les
terrains que nous avons abandonné petit
à petit aux censeurs du politiquement
correct la nation
l'immigration la frontière les classes
moyennes mais aussi l'école la culture
l'écologie le social
parce que sur tous ces sujets petit à
petit nous avons laissé la voix de la
droite reculer eh bien c'est fini
nous ne reculerons plus et je veux que
nous ayons l'audace de remettre à plat
nos idées car il ya des leçons à tirer
de nos échecs la droite virginie doit
assumer un discours courageux dans la
lutte contre le gaspillage de l'argent
public
les français sont las de ces politiques
qui font tant de promesses qui ensuite
sont incapables de faire la moindre
économie et qui viennent après prendre
dans la poche des français
les finances qu'ils ont été incapables
de trouver mais c'est
mais c'est précisément pascal ce que
fait emmanuel macron la dépense publique
va augmenter de 7 milliards il avait
promis d' économiser sur la durée de son
quinquennat
cent vingt mille postes dans la fonction
publique il en supprime dans le
périmètre de l'état cette année 324 il
lui faudra donc un siècle pour arriver à
tenir sa promesse
je lui souhaite longue vie mais croyez
moi on a quand même bien l'intention de
l'arrêter avant
et le résultat où est il
monsieur balladur vous le savez bien le
résultat c'est que quand l'état
n'économise pas il augmente les impôts
on nous a parlé non-stop pendant six
mois de la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation 3 milliards d'euros et ils
voudraient que nous ne parlions pas dans
cette rentrée de l'augmentation de la
csg 23 milliard d'euros je suis
auvergnat et je sais encore compter oui
les impôts augmentent dans notre pays
et nous et nous que proposons nous parce
que ma conviction c'est que la droite
doit tenir ce discours courageux sur les
économies mais que si l'on tient ce
discours courageux sur les économies on
ne peut pas en même temps proposer aux
français un programme dans lequel on
leur dit non seulement on va devoir
faire des efforts mais en plus on va
augmenter vos impôts je veux que la
droite change son logiciel et qu'elles
comprennent qu'on ne peut plus être une
famille politique
aujourd'hui de droite qui propose encore
des programmes avec une augmentation
d'impôt
nous avions dans notre programme
la hausse de la tva je ne veux plus que
cette proposition soit reprise
nous ne pourrons peut-être pas faire
autant de choses que ce que nous avions
prévu mais je veux que nous puissions
venir devant les français en leur disant
c'est la droite et quand vous votez pour
la droite
vous avez une garantie il n'y aura
aucune augmentation d'impôts
sinon les français ne peuvent pas nous
faire confiance
et je l'appliqué évidemment dans ma
région comme bruno dans toutes nos
régions de droite où nous avons tous
refusé de faire des augmentations
d'impôts auvergne rhône alpes et la
région qui a dégagé le plus grand taux
d'économie sur les dépenses de
fonctionnement
je veux que nous n'ayons pas de discours
et que les gens quand ils nous écoutent
puisse se dire je ne juge pas seulement
sur les discours je regarde les actes et
je peux vérifier que ce qu'ils disent
ils le tiennent
sinon plus personne ne peut nous faire
confiance
il faudra du courage parce que si l'on
veut faire des économies il faut un
discours de vérité
il faut sortir évidemment des 35 heures
la france ne pourra pas défendre ses
emplois si elles travaillent moins que
tous nos voisins et je demande
d'ailleurs au gouvernement où est passée
cette promesse dont le président de la
république nous rabat les oreilles quand
il détecte en campagne
la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires la csg ça c'est au
rendez vous par contre la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
c'est oublié rappelons leur ce qu'est la
totalité des promesses qu'il avait tenus
oui il faut que nous portions une
réforme ambitieuse des régimes de
retraite et la seule réforme ambitieuse
des régimes de retraite qui vaille c'est
celle qui mettra à égalité une bonne
fois pour toutes tout les reprennent du
public du privé et la suppression de
tous les régimes spéciaux de retraite
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est pour cela que je n'accepte
pas la façon dont emmanuel macron traite
et parle des retraités en france
les retraités sont les premières
victimes des augmentations d'impôts
ce n'est pas juste on ne peut pas faire
40 % des cadeaux fiscaux cette année aux
5 % des plus riches et augmenter
massivement la csg
le président de la république avait
expliqué que seuls les retraités les
plus aisés seraient concernés j'ai un
couple de retraités de haute loire qui
est venu me voir qui vient d'arriver à
la retraite de retraités modestes qui
tous chacun à peine 1000 euros de
retraite
eh bien ils vont connaître une
augmentation de ses jets de 450 euros
ce n'est pas juste est ce cela monsieur
macron ce que vous appelez les retraités
aisés
est ce cela votre conception de la
justice et de ce qu'est une politique
fiscale
non les retraités ne sont pas des
privilégiés
ils ont souvent travaillé dur ils ont
souvent travaillé beaucoup plus dur que
ce que notre génération ne travaille
actuellement
ils n'ont pas volé leur retraite
elle est le fruit d'une vie de travail
et vous commettez une lourde erreur en
voulant opposer les retraités et les
actifs nous ici nous défendons la
solidarité entre les générations
je veux aussi
comerica le courage de le défendre que
nous puissions lutter contre tous les
gaspillages administratifs toutes les
folies de notre pays qui est capable
d'inventer tendent usine à gaz tant de
normes tant de contraintes en de règles
qui découragent tous ceux qui veulent
faire quelque chose mais en revanche mes
amis je refuserai toujours que notre
famille politique démantèle l'assurance
maladie parce que l'assurance maladie
cela fait partie pour moi de ce qu'est
notre pays et de ce qu'est la france
la générosité de la france c'est cette
promesse qui consiste à offrir à tout
citoyen de notre pays qu'ils soient
riches ou qu'ils soient modestes la
possibilité d'être soignés
de la même manière je crois dans une
droite qui est social je crois dans une
droite qui est exigeante et je crois
dans une droite aussi qu'ils n'oublient
pas les réalisent les racines du
gaullisme social et qui n'oublie pas que
notre droite à nous en france a toujours
été une droite généreuse
c'est pour cela vous le savez que je
vous demande toujours de vous engager
sur les questions du handicap qui sont
si mal traités parce que notre famille
politique a toujours porté la question
du handicap mais je vous demande de
porter notre vision du social qui est
une vision du social à droite
la justice n'est pas un mot de gauche
que je sache je veux que nous tendons la
main à ceux qui en ont vraiment besoin
mais je revendique aussi évidemment la
liberté de dire que nous en avons assez
de fermer les yeux et de nous taire
quand certains profitent du système et
tire sur la corde en affaiblissant la
solidarité nationale
parce que dans bien des cas celui qui
reprend un travail dans notre pays ne
gagne pas plus à la fin du mois que s'il
était resté chez lui à cumuler les
prestations sociales alors cela ne plaît
pas quand on le dit et bien je le dis
car c'est la vérité
les classes moyennes sont trop souvent
les oubliés de notre système social
ceux qui respectent les règles
c'est auxquels on demande sans cesse
plus ceux qui vont être les premières
victimes des augmentations d'impôts
cette année et ceux auxquels on explique
qu ils n'ont jamais droit à rien on ne
peut pas accepter que le gouvernement
remette en cause la politique familiale
et que dans le même temps on continue à
offrir l'accès gratuit à notre système
de solidarité pour des étrangers qui
n'ont même jamais cotisé une heure sur
le sol national
je souhaite aussi dans cette grande
refondation de nos idées que nous
prenions le temps dira génie de
réfléchir à notre approche de l'économie
tu le sais je suis pour les libertés
à l'intérieur j'en ai assez que tous
ceux qui prennent des risques qui créent
de l'emploi montrent leur entreprise ont
le courage de devenir artisan commerçant
reçoivent comme première récompense un
courrier de l'urssaf une visée de
l'inspecteur du travail une augmentation
de charge
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai assez que ceux qui se mettent à
travailler reçoivent comme première
reconnaissance de la part de la
république le fait de leur dire vous
n'avez plus droit à ceci ou vous n'avez
plus le droit à cela je pense que la
lutte sera rude
parce que l'administration a pris le
pouvoir sur le politique dans notre pays
et que nous avons démissionné depuis
beaucoup trop longtemps
nous devons redonner de l'oxygène nous
devons redonner de la compétitivité
nous devons avoir le courage de dire que
ceux qui ont envie de réussir seront
soutenus par la famille des républicains
que ce soit de modeste salarié chez
michelin que ce soit des artisans qui
créent leur petite pme ou que ce soit
des gens qui sont à la tête des grands
groupes du cac 40 et qui font aussi la
fierté de notre pays mais à l'envers ce
je veux aussi que nous soyons lucides
je veux que nous sortions de notre
naïveté dans la proche de la
mondialisation
comment comprendre que la chine elle
ferme l'accès à ses propres marchés
publics et que dans le même temps
l'union européenne offre l'accès à 90%
de notre marché public aux produits
chinois sans que nous ayons la moindre
possibilité de donner la préférence à
nos propres entreprises
notre famille politique a pêché depuis
beaucoup trop longtemps d'une absence de
lucidité sur ces thèmes je réclame que
l'on soit ouvert avec les pays qu'ils
sont ouverts mais je réclame aussi que
l'on soit fermée avec les pays qui sont
fermés et qui ne respectent pas les
règles du jeu
plus de liberté à l'intérieur mais plus
de protection à l'intérieur quand nous
avons en face de nous des pays qui
n'aime pas la même approche
tous les pays au monde le fond le japon
se protègent les états unis favorisent
leurs entreprises et nous serions la
seule zone économique au monde à ne pas
donner la préférence à nos propres
emplois nicolas sarkozy avait sauvé
alstom emmanuel macron la brader en le
vendant aux allemands pour nous le
patriotisme économique n'est pas un gros
mot
il ya une époque michel nadine où
l'europe défende ait la préférence
communautaire
pourquoi avons-nous renoncer
je ne crains pas le débat sur l'europe
je l'attends certains voudraient nous
faire croire jean comme tu l'as si bien
dit que le débat serait entre les pro et
les anti europe
à ma droite marine le pen qui plaide
pour le repli derrière la palissade du
village gaulois et le retour à une
monnaie nationale
une folie dans une époque où la france
doit affronter des pays comme la chine
ou comme les états unis ce que propose
marine le pen c'est juste la faillite
des épargnants de tous ceux qui
travaillent et de toute notre économie
mais à ma gauche emmanuel macron à ma
gauche qui lui propose toujours plus de
ce qui ne marche pas plus de commission
européenne plus d'argent ce
administratives plus d'impôts et surtout
plus d'élargissement je suis pour
l'europe mais c'est parce que je suis
pour l'europe que je veux qu'elle change
nous aurons à combattre deux dangers le
repli sur soi et la fuite en avant vers
toujours plus de ce que les peuples ont
rejeté il faut renforcer erasmus il faut
une europe de la recherche qui soit
capable de trouver le vaccin contre
alzheimer mais à l'envers ce jeu demande
évidemment que nous retrouvions pour
l'immigration notre souveraineté
nationale dans la maîtrise de nos
frontières
parce que schengen ça ne marche plus
et nous aurons de vrais débats et notre
délégation européenne à bruxelles et à
strasbourg a fait avancer bien des
thèmes monsieur macron propose
l'élargissement de l'europe aux pays des
balkans
il propose une nouvelle fois d'élargir
l'europe à l'albanie et à la bosnie
herzégovine à la serbie et à la
macédoine
oui nous aurons un beau débat sur
l'europe les français auront le choix
s'ils veulent que l'europe s'élargisse
encore à de nouveaux pays qu'ils votent
pour en mars s'ils veulent que la
bulgarie rentrer dans schengen qu'ils
votent pour en mars
s'ils veulent une europe qu'on remette
la tête à l'endroit dans laquelle il n'y
aura plus aucun élargissement tant qu'on
n'aura pas refondé l'europe qu'ils
votent pour les républicains
[Applaudissements]
et nous allons ouvrir avec vous tous
cette réflexion en partant de cette idée
fondatrice qu'avait eue
edouard balladur au début des années 90
quand il avait tiré toutes les sonnettes
d'alarmé au moment où l'europe s'est
élargi de façon folle il avait
clairement plaidé pour une europe des
cercles qui soient organisées autour
d'un noyau dur limitée à quelques pays
l'europe fonctionner quand elle était à
12 elles ne marchent plus quand elle est
à 27
il faut organiser différents cercles
pour remettre l'europe sur de bons rails
je demanderai à edouard balladur de
venir nous éclairer dans cette réflexion
sur l'europe
mercialys
[Applaudissements]
et que tous ceux qui veulent l'épauler
soient les bienvenus
[Applaudissements]
mais je veux aussi que nous reprenons à
notre compte les enjeux de demain
il est plus que temps de faire émerger
une écologie de droite
on ne peut continuer à laisser les
thèmes de l'écologie à quelques
ayatollahs qui ne fonctionne que par
interdit que par fermeture ou que par
normes administratives
l'écologie est un gigantesque défi qui
mérite mieux qu'une poignée
d'extrémistes
je crois à une pensée écologique de
droite qui mise sur l'innovation qui
misent sur le projet qu'ils comprennent
que l'on peut tout à la fois créer de
l'emploi et préserver notre
environnement
une écologie qui comprennent que la
première d écologie est d'abord de
remettre les produits de notre
agriculture dans nos assiettes
au lieu de faire venir des produits de
la terre entière fusse-t-il bio une
écologie qui est le souci gérard comme
tu l'as si bien dit de la défense des
territoires de tous les territoires de
cette france parfois dédaigné par
emmanuel macron cette france des
départements
cette france des petites villes cette
france des mers auquel il a tourné le
dos cette france dans laquelle il
n'investit plus nous nous devons tenir
cette promesse qui était si belle de la
république française de porter à la fois
la fierté de la capitale parisienne mais
aussi de dire qu'une petite commune de
la creuse de la lozère ou de l'aveyron
doit avoir accès à la même égalité des
chances c'est cela l'écologie de droite
à laquelle nous croyons
c'est une écologie bruno qui défend les
valeurs profondes qui sont les nôtres
qui sont celles des terroirs qui sont
celles de la transmission qui sont
celles de l'appartenance à une maison
commune avec ses paysages sa nature et
son identité
il paraît que c'est un mot qu'on a plus
le droit d'employer son identité ce qui
fait que pour nous quand on parle
d'écologie
nous pensons à chacun de ces petits
bouts de france qui nous émeuvent
l'écologie de l'enracinement cet
enracinement dont parlait si bien la
philosophe simone weil les racines
disait tél il faut retrouver ce
sentiment de tendresse poignante pour
une chose belle pour une chose précieuse
pour une chose fragile et périssable il
faut donner quelque chose a aimé et ce
quelque chose
ce doit être la france ça c'est
l'écologie de la droite
alors oui vous l'avez compris je refuse
de laisser le monopole du social à la
gauche je refuse que nous continuions à
reculer sur tous ces thèmes que nous
avons petit à petit abandonné et qui ont
été usurpés par en marche mais je refuse
aussi de laisser le monopole de la
sécurité ou de l'immigration
à l'extrême droite vous avez vu vous
avez vu la façon dont on cherche à nous
faire taire sur ce sujet ça fait trop
longtemps que quand on les aborde
nous avons pris l'habitude de mettre du
papier de soie de surtout prendre un
luxe infinie de précaution de langage
pour s'assurer que personne ne
comprennent rien à ce qu'on veut dire et
pour que surtout à l'arrivée personne ne
puisse nous reprocher d'avoir outragé
tous les censeurs du politiquement
correct qui peuplent les débats de notre
pays
et pourtant guillaume et pourtant il n'a
jamais été aussi important de se battre
pour que la france prenne la mesure du
défi
alors je le dis avec fermeté emmanuel
macron capitule face à l'insécurité
depuis son élection il a gravement
sous-estimé ses sujets et aujourd'hui
c'est la réalité qui lui saute au visage
celle de la caserne de grenoble qui a
été incendié
celle des policiers de champigny qui ont
été attaqué sauvagement celle des
pompiers
le jour de la saint sylvestre qui sont
caillassés quand il vend dans des
quartiers pour sauver des vies celle des
gardiens de prison qui ont poussé un cri
de détresse
confronté à la montée de la
radicalisation islamique dans les
prisons les derniers chiffres de la
délinquance sont alarmants avec
notamment une explosion des attaques
contre les forces de l'ordre
chaque jour en france ce sont 90
agressions qui ont lieu chaque jour
contre des gendarmes contre des
policiers contre des forces de l'ordre
des agressions qui ont souvent lieu avec
des armes à feu
c'est cela aujourd'hui la réalité de
l'insécurité dans notre pays et cette
réalité s'explique par une évidence il
n'y a plus d'autorité
il n'y a plus de crainte
il n'y a plus de respect
aujourd'hui ce sont les voyous qui
imposent leur loi et ils le font parce
qu'ils savent que dans notre pays on est
rarement poursuivis ils le font parce
encore plus rarement condamnés ils le
font parce qu'ils savent que dans notre
pays
les peines sont encore moins exécuté
les chiffres sont terribles
il y à 70 mille détenus en france et il
y à cent mille peines non exécutées ou
en cours d'exécution
autrement dit il y a plus de condamnés
en liberté en france que de condamner en
prison
la réalité c'est que quand un policier
est attaqué et qu'il doit sortir son
arme pour se défendre il est obligé de
réfléchir à deux fois
parce qu'il sait que c'est lui ensuite
qui sera traîné devant la justice et qui
devra s'excuser
et que fait le gouvernement philippe
rien j'accuse
emmanuel macron d'avoir gravement
sous-estimé
tous ces sujets et comment d'ailleurs un
gouvernement qui a cédé devant une
petite poignée 2 à 10 pourrait-il avoir
la fermeté nécessaires pour faire face à
l'insécurité et aux délinquants dans
notre pays
je les observe depuis huit mois et je
vois clairement que l'autorité n'est pas
une valeur en marche
ils n'ont rien changé aux loi taubira
le ministre de l'intérieur nous fait
perdre du temps avec sa police de
sécurité du quotidien au lieu de
s'occuper de la sécurité quotidienne des
policiers ils n'ont emporté aucune loi
pour renforcer les peines ils ont réduit
de façon absurde leur programme de
construction de places de prison et la
garde des sceaux parle d'aménagement de
peine elle veut moins de peine de prison
nous nous voulons plus de place en
prison
eux sont dans la culture du laxisme
et je voulais dit il nous faut porter
des propositions précises et nous
demandons l'abaissement de la majorité
pénale pour répondre à la violence d'une
délinquance de plus en plus précoce nous
demandons en urgence la construction de
quinze mille nouvelles places de prison
dans les quatre ans qui viennent
conformément aux engagements qui avaient
été pris et nous proposons avec force
l'instauration qui n'a jamais été fait
en france
deux peines planchers pour tous ceux qui
s'en prennent aux forces de l'ordre
je ne comprends pas pourquoi le
gouvernement refuse cette mesure de bon
sens c'est une mesure de bon sens parce
qu'il faut tout simplement que la peur
change de camp
parce qu'il faut tout simplement que
quand les voyous s'en prennent à nos
forces de l'ordre il faut qu'il
comprenne enfin qu'ils seront condamnés
et qu'ils seront condamnés à des peines
lourdes après les incidents terribles
qui ont eu lieu depuis plus d'un mois et
demi dans notre pays et qui ont donné
lieu à si peu de réactions de la part du
gouvernement
je veux dire ici avec la plus forte des
autorités que nos policiers et nos
gendarmes
nos gardiens de prison nos pompiers
peuvent savoir qu'ils trouveront
toujours dans notre famille politique
un soutien parce que chez nous on ne se
trompe pas un délinquant
ça n'est pas une victime de l'oppression
sociale
cette un délinquant et quand il a fait
un délit
sa place est en prison
je voudrais enfin mes amis finir par la
question de l'immigration
il faut que vous sachiez qu'en 2017
notre pays a délivré deux cent soixante
mille titres de séjour et je ne parle
bien sûr que des étrangers en situation
irrégulière autant que la ville de
bordeaux
c'est un record jamais depuis 40 ans
notre pays n'avait accepté autant
d'immigrés en une année et pourtant
notre situation n'a rien à voir avec
celle qui était celle de la france dans
les années 70 notre chômage pour nos
jeunes
notre situation économique les
difficultés de l'intégration la montée
de l'intégrisme islamique devrait
pourtant nous conduire à ce constat qui
n'est que trop évident il y a trop
d'immigration en france et il faut
réduire de façon drastique l'immigration
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
les mesures proposées par le
gouvernement ne sont absolument pas à la
hauteur du défi
on fait semblant de s'occuper du sujet
en nous amuse on traite uniquement la
partie du droit d'asile
c'est à dire quarante mille personnes
sur les deux cent soixante mille titres
de séjour qui sont délivrés maintenant
dans notre pays je propose que nous
remettions à plat la totalité de notre
politique migratoire
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucun outil
qui fonctionne nous donnons parfois la
nationalité à des personnes qui ne
maîtrisent même pas correctement le
français
nous ne reconduisons plus à la frontière
les étrangers qui ont été déboutés du
droit d'asile
que l'on soit en réalité réguliers ou
irréguliers à l'arrivée la force de la
république et de la loi n'est même plus
assurée cela ne marche plus il faut
ouvrir son tabou le débat les français
vous vous avez droit à ce débat cela
fait trop longtemps que notre pays
accueille chaque année plus d'étrangers
sans que nous nous interrogions à un
seul moment sur nos capacités d'accueil
faut-il garder le regroupement familial
faut-il adopter les quotas pour
l'immigration choisie
peut-on continuer à accueillir un tel
nombre d'étudiants étrangers alors que
pour une partie
il détourne les règles qui sont les
nôtres ne doit-on pas revenir sur le
droit du sol ou sur le code de la
nationalité
sur tous ces sujets sur tous ces sujets
notre famille politique doit être celle
qui aura le courage d'ouvrir le débat et
je le dis calmement mais fermement
ce n'est pas aux passeurs de décider de
qui rentrent en france 7 offrant
c'est de décider qu'ils veulent ou
qu'ils ne veulent pas accueillir sur le
sol de la république française
alors oui mes amis
il nous faudra du courage oui mes amis
tout commence il faudra du temps et il
ne faudra pas plier face aux attaques et
au moment où nous allons entamer ce
grand défi je vous demande d'avoir
confiance
ne doutez pas portez en vous cette
phrase de ce poète que j'aime tant yves
bonnefoy émis 7 heures mes amis ou se
dénoue les signes c'est presque laumes
oui c'est presque l'aube pour les
républicains
mes amis je veux sortir la politique du
double langage je crois que si notre
pays a tant de difficultés c'est parce
que depuis beaucoup trop longtemps les
politiques ont pris l'habitude de
vouloir tout concilier de trop chercher
à plaire de ne pas assumer de choix de
dire à chacun ce qu'ils avaient envie
d'entendre
je crois que cette politique là ne dit
plus rien et qu'elle ne fait plus rien
c'est la politique du en même temps
c'est la politique qui prétend changer
le code du travail tout en requérant les
sourires des syndicats c'est la
politique qui prétend réformer l'état
mais qui laisse filer la dépense
publique c'est la politique qui supprime
la taxe d'habitation mais qui en réalité
augmente la csg c'est la politique qui
en matière d'immigration prétend faire
de l'humanité et de la fermeté et qui ne
fait ni l'un ni l'autre
cette politique n'a rien de neuf c'est
la politique des non choix c'est celle
qui a amené la france dans la situation
dans laquelle nous sommes
c'est la politique de l' ambiguïté
permanente
alors oui elle peut plaire un temps mais
je suis convaincu qu elle se conclura
par de lourdes déception parce que faute
de courage elle ne va jamais au bout des
choix qui s'imposent
lincoln le disait si bien on peut
tromper une partie du peuple tout le
temps on peut tromper tout le peuple une
partie du temps mais on ne peut pas
tromper tout le peuple tout le temps
monsieur macron ferait bien de méditer
cette phrase on ne tue pas la france sur
la durée et bien moi je vous invite à
cette politique des convictions je vous
invite à cette politique du courage je
vous invite à cette politique
qu'attendent les français parce qu'elle
seule a le courage de dire à voix haute
ce que trop d'élus ne veulent plus voir
je vous invite à la seule politique qui
redonnera à notre pays ces valeurs je
vous invite à sonner le réveil de la
france vive la république et vive la
france
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
i
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais passer pour
l'entreprise l'ordinaire